foreign
[Music]
Mori buntaro is like a lot of us
after transferring to a new high school
everyone can clearly see that this quiet
reserved and disinterested new student
doesn't care for class or making friends
and some students try to take advantage
of that Miyamoto a student climber
pushes Maury around claiming he's just
acting up to get attention he tells him
he'll leave him alone if he climbs up
the side of the school of course
Miyamoto doesn't expect Mori to really
do it and if he does to not get far at
all and quit frustrated and embarrassed
ultimately his end goal
but as he watches Mori starts scaling
the building those thoughts of
humiliating him vanish
climbing up and up Mori doesn't quite
understand what he's doing or why he's
doing it but his body moves nonetheless
he comes face to face with an overhang
the likes of which even Miyamoto
wouldn't try for without a harness like
Mori is doing now
the kind of jump that would kill you if
you failed call it a disregard for his
life unwavering determination or perhaps
both
but more he leapt
and as he surged forward alone as he
reached for the sky's embrace it is only
when his scraped hands grip upon that
ledge that a particular energy and
excitement surges through his body
for the first time ever Mori finally
feels alive
he is infatuated with this feeling
laying on the roof of the school
building and looking up at the sky as if
his hands can for once actually bring
him somewhere can pull him out of this
hole in life and allow him to reach
Heights where no one else can touch him
after onishi Sensei who teaches Miyamoto
climbing sees this feat from Ori and
asks him to climb more and practice with
them
but Mori doesn't need things like
friends
still Mori can't escape that feeling of
melting into the sky of freeing himself
from the shackles of society
he keeps climbing
and despite mori's insistence to be
alone onishi Sensei continues to
encourage him showing him to nearby
mountains and feeding off the budding
excitement he senses in Mori he pushes
him to join a rock climbing competition
he gives him climbing shoes he opens up
a new rock climbing Club at school he
watches as that new student who did the
overhang finds purpose a place he can
climb to and discover a new self
but as we read further Mori continues to
become more and more infatuated with the
idea of solo climbing often regarded as
suicide to most professionals climbing
alone has allowed the mountains to claim
an endless number of lives leaving their
fallen bodies upon the heights become a
frozen Eternal memory of the life that
once was
the mountain is a place where you must
be ready to give up your life
but the stories from onishi Sensei and
other climbers somehow do not dissuade
Mori who seems to have a death wish to
them all
why does he desire it so much
[Music]
have you ever felt so alone that you
believed that separating yourself from
people entirely rejecting connections
and telling yourself you don't need them
would make that crippling loneliness go
away
pain of losing a friend being bullied
falling hopelessly in love that none of
it would happen if you left it all
behind
if you never made that friend never
spoke or acted to draw the attention of
those bullies closed yourself off from
even thinking you needed or deserved
love to keep yourself away from
heartbreak
this is slowly revealed to be how Mori
thinks and the sad thing is that I can
perfectly understand him
I'm sure many introverted people here
can the pain of Hope
ing that you have a chance at making
those connections but after failure and
failure again feeling that pushing that
hope away will just make it all a bit
less painful
in these cases it is often through
hobbies and passions that we can still
find meaning
for me in high school it was anime the
relationships I had were with the
characters on the screen the stories
they wove
a point in my life I was absorbing
myself in these endless fictional worlds
where I could forget the pain of the one
I really lived in
for Mori
that's what climbing is
where all of the dirty and unpleasant
things of the worlds below get washed
away in the pure whiteness of the snowy
mountain tops
the climber's story evolves in a very
interesting way most notably the
remarkable thematic shift following
volume 3. everything I've described so
far of the story is actually remarkably
different in tone from the majority of
this psychological scene and Story the
climber was originally a collaboration
between the writer nabero yoshiro and
artist shinichi Sakamoto nabera however
left at the time at the end of the third
volume due to creative differences
leaving Sakamoto in charge of both the
writing and the art this part of the
climber experiences what's called
cerebus syndrome coins by Eric Burns
white based on the comic book cerebus
The Aardvark it's when a story or Series
starts out light episodic and comedic
and suddenly assumes dramatic elements
and a more coherent continuity
in the climber a tried and true Sports
manga at first a young lonely Prodigy
found by a teacher who believes in him
and a rival classmate who can push him
joining the school club with the cute
Club manager quickly and completely
shifts into the psychological and
introspective character study that it's
now famous for at this point in volume 3
we also see a key subplot involving a
French suicide in mori's earlier life
that's completely dropped which was
presumably set up by the former writer
nabera characters from the early story
who reappear after the third volume all
have their character development going
completely unexpected directions as well
this change however isn't as abrupt or
disruptive as it seems on surface level
in fact it lines up very well with the
story's continuity
up until this point Mori slowly let
others get close he learned alongside
Miyamoto came to appreciate and listen
to onishi's advice
the finale of volume 3 destroys that it
marks a moment where mori's belief that
he only brings harm to those around him
and only serves to inflict pain on
himself by letting others get close
proves to be true once again
that any hope he had of it not being so
is crushed
to match this sakamoto's art becomes
much darker and more consistent making
the story after volume 3 feel like an
entirely different manga
but this is one of the very few times
where I feel that the story benefited
greatly from the original writer
departing as this is where the climber
truly begins and cements itself as one
of the best
it introduces the Doom magnet Trope that
is often shared among the most popular
scene in manga
let me explain
[Music]
suffering in fiction manga especially
commonly manifests so that no matter
what the protagonist does they only
bring harm to people who try to get
close
berserk one of the most obvious and
famous examples pits guts against
enemies night after night they quite
literally will kill anyone near and
around guts the sacrifice
this can also manifest in the form of
repenting for one's guilt as in Finland
Saga where thorfin feels that after all
the peoples he's killed in the blood he
has spilled he can only bring harm to
people around him
look all around us in all kinds of
fictional Works Batman and the death of
Robin
Frodo carrying the ring of power alone
Dr Frankenstein and his creation
these ideas perpetuate the Trope of the
Doom mag a protagonist who inevitably
brings and attracts Doom to his friends
loved ones and even someone he makes the
slightest form of contact with to some
kind of wretched fate or death
the climber is no exception and similar
to Finland Saga this takes shape in the
form of survivor's guilt
[Music]
throughout mori's story he has shown
time and time again that his attempts to
hold people close to him or more often
the case when he falls into situations
where he must be close to people despite
his rejection of it will result in their
deaths leaving him as the only one to
continue on
the ones who survive are made to carry
the heavy burdens of the Dead
the fact that he doesn't choose to be in
these situations makes the feeling of
guilt even stronger as well Mori feels
like no matter how hard he even tries to
avoid these situations
he can't escape them
and people will still suffer
[Music]
but one of the greatest Parts about
these stories of suffering is the
Redemption
it is the moment where the characters
finally find someone who not only
Remains by their side and wears away at
the binds of the Doom magnet
someone who accepts the character for
who they are as well
our Samwise Ganges are gudrids the
reason these characters get so much rise
out of us as fans readers consumers is
our innate desire to find that partner
of our own or if we already have one to
be grateful for them
someone who provides unwavering support
and reminds us that perhaps this feeling
is worth the pain I've experienced up
until now
the real theme of the climber is that no
matter how hard you try to run away from
people you can never Escape
no man can ever truly be alone an island
unto himself but some people make that
suffering worth it
the climber is an incredible story of
Pain suffering crippling loneliness and
of redemption
for anyone who feels like they aren't
enough or that the struggle to make
connections and keep relationships just
feels like failure time and time again I
think you might find Solace and perhaps
hope in this story
I hope that doesn't disappear
and if you don't feel that way I imagine
this beautifully drawn and written manga
might still give you a story that'll
change your life
[Music]
as always this has been the anime
culture corner I hope you enjoyed the
video don't forget to like And subscribe
for future in-depth show manga and
character analyzes